Have you heard of the natural viral therapy called rigveer? Info is at rigveer.com.
I suggest everybody go and look at that. Rigveer is like at Epley's toxins that I wrote about
in my book. It's actually giving a mixture of different viral toxins to stimulate
and immune response. It can be very beneficial for a lot of different cancers.
It says this person wrote the protocols administered here in the states by a doctor in Mediapolis.
So I don't know of that doctor. I do know that this doctor is got to be tried to probably try to fly
under the radar or he's going to end up getting excited by the medicine aboard.
So please be praying for this guy who's trying to do some good for people.
So it is injectable and what does is it stimulates an infection
and which stimulates an immune response. No different than what we've been saying for years and years that
it can actually be good for a patient with cancer to get an infection, to get a cold, to get a strap,
to get something like that. That's going to stimulate an immune response.
Of course, that's within reason. It doesn't make any sense. Of course, it is super, super ill and
you know, it doesn't have the strength to administer an infection,
or if they're undergoing immunotherapy or chemotherapy or something like that where they have a diminished white blood cell count.
But when you get a cold or when you get a strap infection, or when you encounter somebody at work that has a cold or a strap,
and you know, viruses and bacteria are ubiquitous. They're everywhere. You go everywhere.
So this is the whole foolishness of this whole 2020 thing that you're going to wear a mask and not have a virus exposure.
If you're wearing a mask, you're protected yourself from a virus or even a bacteria.
You are uninformed, let's say. So you are going to be exposed to things and that is what builds your immune system.
What's a strong immune system? Why should you have your kids go play in the dirt?
Because when they're exposed to different pathogens that are fairly harmless pathogens, your body then has to respond to those pathogens by stimulated in the immune response.
And if you fire a TH1 and then a TH2 B cell response, you'll develop antibodies to those pathogens.
And that's the definition of a quote unquote strong immune system. I have a strong immune system. What does that mean?
That means I have a lot of circulated antibodies against a lot of different pathogens. That's the definition of a strong immune system.
So the more that you could expose yourself to different pathogens that aren't going to kill you and your body can fire a TH1 response,
which is a natural killer cell response, and then fire a TH2 response, which is your B cell response where you make antibodies and you make antibodies to that pathogen.
Now you have circulated antibodies to that pathogen and that's really what you want.
Well, natural ring beer therapy is just that you're firing in immune response. It's giving you a pathogen so that you fire in immune response.
Not enough of a pathogen to make you sick, but just enough to make you fire in immune response. So that's the idea of that. Now it was Ebley's toxins.
This guy created it back in the 1950s, I believe, and he was riled as a, you know, a heretic to the medical profession and all this stuff was just horrible.
So now they're trying to do it again. This is not made in the United States. This is a drug so we can't administer it in our clinic.